all right everybody I literally just got
back from watching a paranormal activity
3 and I'm gonna do the pom review
tomorrow's I don't have the makeup on
right now and yeah of course like any
sequel that I do I have to say what I
thought of the other sequels got it
review a lot of sequels somebody many
who the first paranormal activity I
thought it was okay I respected more
what it did to the audience that I did
the actual film I liked that the
audience was being scared by things that
weren't really there is stuff you didn't
see I like the build-up of the tension
stuff and the the way part where I
thought I get really scary was the sort
of the two money shots at the end the
guide towards the camera and then the I
liked her smiling the bed those were
those were scary scenes I like those
those are effective the rest I see him
before but good I was born happy people
gasp gigabyte second one love the second
one one of the best sequels I've ever
seen in my opinion I thought was scary
I thought the acting was so much better
I thought the I thought was very
believable
I liked this family I didn't like the
two in the first one um the something
about the acting just just didn't it
always felt like they were acting the
second one I felt like this like I was
watching a real family so I enjoy it and
the worst and forced things but I liked
how well it tied into the first one it
was a true sequel it explained more
while upping the scares as well and I
that's my favorite one so now we have
the third one which in my opinion is
both a step forward like the second one
took and a step backwards to the first
way it sort of like a perfect mix of the
two which for me anyway creates a movie
that's you know decent there's a lot of
stuff that really really works well in a
lot of stuff that doesn't I'll first
tell you the stuff that doesn't got
these people are idiots I am so sick of
stupid people in horror films and here's
the thing you come to expect it you
really do it's like okay you know
they're gonna be dumb and horror of it
you know they just are but when you get
to the second one
these characters are actually pretty
smart and they start doing smart things
and I and the scares are a little bit
more clever and they're not as
predictable and then they sort of keep
you on your toes that's why it bother me
that the people were so stupid in this
one because it really seemed like a step
backwards after the second one on top of
that the acting is about as good as the
first one away that was a huge fan of
the acting the first one so it's it's
okay but you're always aware you're
watching a movie so that that's a little
distracting the two girls are really
good the two kids in the movie that they
do a pretty good job the ending for me
was sort of the biggest problem which I
won't reveal here I'll tell you I'll
tell you more about later and I'll just
say hey here's the spoiler part so I
won't spoil it but it also a problem
with me so that's the bad stuff oh I
know there's one other thing that really
annoy me okay you need again you need
jump scares in your movie got it both
the other parent or McDivitt ease they
had a few jump scares you know just the
oh it's just her it's not and then you
know to build up for when the real jump
scares come out they do so many in this
one and some are good like the first
couple are good and some of them do make
you jump but it's not it's not scary
it's just a jump and it's great watching
with audience yeah but it's not really
scary and they really serve over abuse
it in the first hand and I know why
because I'm sure they're setting up more
story they plan to set up a lot more
story to this one so but people need to
be scared or else the abd people are
gonna go hoop and you know and run out
now I'm gonna have a TD people complain
anyway I probably have a TD so I have no
one to talk but anyway so that's really
abused okay so that's that's the bad
stuff the good stuff is that they do try
again some new scares which I really
like um the most ingenious thing in this
movie
my opinion is they have these you know
the guy who sets up these cameras again
you know and we've done this before but
this is smart well first of all it's a
stepfather so all the stuff going on in
the house you don't think he'd be
freaked out on it not the mother because
the mother has kids she hears this stuff
all the time kids walk around kids make
noise they get up in the middle of the
night you know kids talk to imaginary
friends so this isn't new to her so it
was very smart to make it a stepfather
who's suspicious about this in her and
not believe it though again we've seen
that dumbass guy
these movies are anti mad okay I don't
know if I'm a man of mister whatever who
are these but these are very anti men
movie if you ever notice that the men in
these movies are jackasses they're
morons they're jerks
no one's own them but anyway they need
someone to make this stupid mistakes and
and coax the ghosts you know so um but
the most of genius thing I was getting
to is that he he sets up this camera
using a fan you know goes back and forth
I was very smart but so you have this
shot that very slowly moves to the left
very slowly moves to the right and they
use this shot a lot and of course you're
gonna set up some great scares with it
because as you're slowly moving to the
left you're looking around what do you
guys see you know something slowly
revealing and slowly moves back and then
with slowly moves the other way again
it's not gonna be there or it's got to
be closer or maybe something was set out
of place or you know maybe the monster
or the ghost is there it's very slowly
being revealed it's a great setup it's
really really smart
um and I get any time it would leave a
your goings go they didn't know what
they're gonna see so that was wonderful
um another good thing about is that they
are continuing the story with this or
sort of the backstory and for the most
part it's good and the girl speaking to
the you know the imaginary friend is
very convincing you know she's she does
a really good job and the actual one the
scares I think about halfway through the
scares when the real scare start
happening this
real hate this was meant to really scare
you they're good and they're creative
and there's a lot of Oh scenes where the
person's coaxing the goes like the girls
like you know oh you're a baby there's
no magic friend there's no Toby doesn't
mean this imaginary friend he's in there
and you go oh really
come on Toby I'm coming inside and that
that's great for an audience everyone
but that's a little kid so she's allowed
to be stupid the other I don't know but
all right so uh so the build-up of
suspense is good and a lot of scares are
very creative mean you don't always know
where they're going
I'm it's something that's really odd I
don't know whether or not I like it I
think a lot of people including myself
we're disappointed how much they were
revealing in the coming attraction not
one clip from any of the commercials or
the previews is in this movie how
freaking weird is that I've never seen
that happen there's always a clip or two
that doesn't make it in a movie this has
none
none of us eat the the Bloody Mary the
girl jumping off the stairs throwing the
water and something there this doctor
guy who's I've been in the movie or
whatever saying you have to get out of
his head lines in there
it's so weird so I I don't know what to
think that cuz on the one hand I'm glad
all the scares weren't given away but
that's sort of the exact explanation of
false advertising isn't it now one clip
was in the movie so I don't know I'm
sort of torn about it but um so don't
worry about that now with all that said
I guess before I go into the spoiler
territory I'll just say that I did like
the movie The Annoying parts really got
annoying to me I liked it a little
better than the first one actually maybe
about the half as much as the first one
add 1/2 to the first one because um yeah
first one I could usually see the scares
coming in stuff this one I couldn't see
the scares as much one the halfway point
hit and I liked that and to keep me on
my toes so it has that going for it but
they make the same dumb mistakes they do
in the first one so it's so I wrote she
has a step backwards a step forward
it's worth it for the steps forward do
you know because they're they're good
skiers alright now I'm gonna head into
spoiler territory uh I'll just say I did
not get the ending I didn't really
understand it and I don't know if it's
just build-up for the next film or if
you're just supposed to get it which is
so strange because the other films were
so exact in this is what happened you
know and this is what's going on and
this one leads this very kind of
confusing ending and what I did is I
actually looked up Brad and Noah's
reviews which critics are never supposed
to do you know you're not supposed to
listen to other critics instead this way
you get to steal their opinion I know I
know a lot of critics don't like to do
that I guess it feels gonna like
influence their thought or something
like that it's like I don't know if you
like something like if you don't like it
don't like it you know but I digress um
I was watching their reviews just to see
if I missed something
and apparently yeah there's just a lot
of things that are unexplained and it's
probably build-up for you know number
four which I'm very happy to see I like
these movies but I think for an audience
they're gonna feel really ripped off by
them there and they're gonna feel
frustrating they're gonna feel stupid
you know because I gave - did I miss
something did I wait because the other
two I mean they carried into the next
one but they also you know they were
self explanatory they were
self-contained and this one isn't and
that can be very frustrating for people
I mean it's very frustrating for me and
it's a good climax it's a good build-up
and good scary images and I guess the
idea is it's probably suggesting or kind
of creepy but you can't fully connect it
to the other films yet you're just sort
of raising more questions like we'll
wait well then how did this happen here
how did it
it is pretty much with when I'm giving
away too much give away a little the two
girl the two little girls go with the
grandma who it's revealed as the bad guy
which is not a big shock and they're
pretty much agreeing to be possessed and
become these demons and they're very
happy about it they're gonna be what the
goes and stuff like that
well what does that mean for
other films what does that mean you know
did they totally repress it did they
tell it you know cuz they don't seem to
be on board for you know giving up their
kid or whatever or mention to anyone
else or anything like that they seemed
legitimately freaked out you know like
and you know I gained normal person
would so um you know who didn't go
through this weird so that really
really bothered me and I found it very
distracting yeah I know a lot of other
people did too they just sort of went
well that's it why and it was a good
climax if there was good scares and good
build-up and again they're upping the
creepy imagery which I love but it was
no you know the delivery was not a full
delivery it was a half delivery and I
suppose watching both Noah and Brad that
they say is probably just building for
the fourth one um okay I the two movies
because they could be self-contained as
well and there was nothing in here that
directly said to be continued or another
it's not like Empire Strikes Back where
obviously there's gonna be another one
so that bothered me greatly but aside
from that it's I said the first half you
just said the first half plays very much
to the audience the first half very much
wants the Anya's go to the Brad to go
it's there's a lot of that and I find
that kind of tiring but uni the
atmosphere you need the buildup it's in
the 80s so they I mean everyone's like
what you think the Teddy Ruxpin and
stuff it's very clever
um I'm both delighted and disappointed
they didn't actually make it move it
probably shows great restraint because
in reality that would have been too
silly and that would have been going to
a fire but everybody wants to see they
don't get some nice creepy shots of it
though and that's very smart so uh yeah
like I said if I was to let's list these
and or ISM order of my favorites it
probably be two three
one to be my favorite so yeah that's
about it for a paranormal activity 3 I
even though I thought the ending if it
is just bill up for the fourth one I
think it could been done better but I
look forward to a fourth one I do like
these movies and I wanted to keep seeing
him I like that they can be made so
quickly and with so little and they use
it to their advantage although it is
interesting we look at the credits the
credits are about as long as any other
movie and you think these are video
cameras and these are some computer
effects and just like five people in the
film how does this fill up all these
credits so bright a lot more work is put
into it than I think but it takes a lot
of work to make a movie everything so um
alright I'm just rambling here I did
enjoy it
I had some problems with it but I liked
it and if you don't like the timer
activity films this isn't gonna you know
turn you it's gotta be as boring or
whatever you don't like about any other
ones but it a lot of it is repeat but
when I did up the scares it did it very
cleverly and very effectively so that's
my final word
take care